you ever go to the gym and there's this
one person you see all the time at the
gym same place you've been going to you
see this person working out so hard it's
almost as if every time you go to the
gym they're there but you don't see any
progress with their body how is that
even possible
see the same goes to a business in
business you have two different people
let's just say we have Bobby and we have
Joey okay Bobby and Joe we both became
an entrepreneur at the same exact time
same exact time they're both willing to
work 80 hours a week they're all the
timers they're willing to work 80 hours
a week but two years later three years
later five years later
Bobby's business does five million year
Joey's business only there's a couple
hundred thousand dollars per year why is
that right why is it how's that even
possible and Joey is going crazy
thinking what is Bobby doing did he get
lucky nope
Bobby know how to prioritize his time
and Bobby gets credit for putting a
better strategy in place while working
very hard okay so I'm gonna explain to
you today the strategy quadrant and my
outcome today this video is not for
everybody so this video is now for
somebody who's a part-timer this video
is for somebody who's minimum minimum
working 60 hours and up and is wanting
to take their business from doing a
million dollars a year to two four ten
20 million dollar in your business
you're not looking at doing some small
you want to exponentially grow your
business so now you have four things
entrepreneurs sometimes say Pat I feel
like I'm doing so many different things
and a veteran an expert entrepreneur
will rarely say say I'm being very
overwhelmed okay you rarely hear
somebody who knows what they're doing
they're overwhelmed typically amateurs
say I'm very overwhelmed and I feel I
got to do this and I'm doing that and
I'm doing this and I'm doing this and
this is just too much I don't know if I
can do this right okay great you're
really doing four things as a CEO and an
entrepreneur it's four things you're
really doing you're either working on
your next innovative campaigning you're
either developing leaders you're either
making your operating system better or
you're doing business in sales very
simple one thing to keep in mind any
time you spend time here on the bottom
this is linear which means your business
doesn't explode it's linear this is like
somebody who has a liquor store or rest
Terron and they make burgers or they
sell beer and every year they gross
$600,000 years a year they gross a
million ear they gross $300,000 a year
and they're happy with that that's what
their growth in every single year and
it's been the same for ten years because
their main focus is here so it's linear
hasn't exploded right and over here you
got the exponential side when you focus
on next innovation innovative campaign
and leadership development now before I
go into this and dive into this with you
I want you to understand what you do
also have to has to do with when you do
it for instance every business goes
through a different phase four phases
they go through one is the survival
which saves the beginning of the
business at any point you can go out of
business that's a startup phase okay
the other one is formulation you're
putting the pieces together because
you're preparing for what an explosion
and then when you have an explosion at
the end most companies almost every one
of them if not every one of them you
will hit a plateau right you will hit a
plateau but it's very important for you
to be prepared for this explosion that's
going to take place and how do you
maximize that explosion so now with that
being said let's talk about what these
four things are that you'll be doing as
an entrepreneur first one next
innovative campaign this is very simple
let me explain to what I mean by this
right now it's holiday season okay
Christmas is around the corner new years
is coming everybody by January 1st is
going to be judged on the type of
campaign they ran during this season
everybody they're going to get judged on
what type of a campaign they run during
this season there is dealerships that
have to hit their numbers by the end of
the year so you'll hear a lot of
creative innovative campaign saying you
know if you buy brand new Hyundai the
next 60 days we're going to pay for your
gas the next two years oh wow honey we
can buy a car and they're going to pay
for two years of our gas what they're
really saying is instead of selling you
the car for 28 grand they'll sell it to
you for 24 grand and that four thousand
is two years of gas but it's an
innovative campaign get you to come in
you know Walmart may say you know during
the holiday season we have a sale
on these three products why those three
products because they're the most
popular selling products that brings us
in then we buy a bunch of other things
that's their innovative campaign
everybody gets judged on this
unfortunately even as a real estate
agent or financial advisor insurance
FinTech whatever business you're in
every business has a next innovative
campaign and those who don't have
constant next innovative campaigns they
don't have the inevitable explosion
that's exponential not steady linear
exponential the other one is leadership
development leadership development is
you always identifying who the next
leaders you're going to build from the
moment I figured out this business for
longest time my business was linear the
first two years and then I said look I
want to experience an explosion I want
to take my business from doing a hundred
thousand dollars per year to doing tens
of millions of dollars per year how do I
do this everything came back down to
leadership development so you take your
business whatever you have and you sit
and say who do I have at the home office
that can make into a major leader in the
company and you make a list of your top
five top three whoever the people are
and you start assessing them and you say
this person needs this their strengths
or this their weaknesses or this this
personal response to this they don't
respond to this they're very competitive
they're not competitive they're very
sensitive you know he's always coming up
with ideas man he's so solid he's got
poise I like this guy is he does he
believe in the company is he in it so
what can I do with them then you sit
down and you start identifying what
things he needs to do next three six
twelve months two years and you
presented to him then you work on him
you challenge him or her to grow you do
the same thing with your executive
salespeople up-and-coming people doesn't
matter what it is you as a CEO as an
entrepreneur are going to get judged
based on the types of leaders you
develop yesterday Tom and I were in New
York we were on a flight we're coming
back and and Tom said we were talking
about Bill Belichick Bill Belichick
coach of a New England Patriots and I
say hey Tom I got a question for he says
what's that I said how many coaches that
have worked
under Belichick have won a Super Bowl
championship they were assistant coaches
says you know what actually nobody I sir
really says don't nobody I said it's so
interesting because you know Bill Walsh
is known for what Bill Walsh was known
for having produced the most people who
went on and won championships for
themselves because Bill Walsh is a
phenomenal developer of leaders now Bill
Belichick is phenomenal at building
players into leaders not coaches but
players that was his strength so if
you're a player playing for him you're
gonna win but coaches was a different
story right you're gonna get judged
based on how whatever job you do will
leadership development because this is
exponential a part of this could be as
you're looking at next people to recruit
to bring to your company that certain
talent then a linear side is operating
system and biz dev let me explain
operating system operating system to
most people who are watching is if
you're a type personality or your market
or sales CEO type of a personality this
is boring there's nothing exciting
matter operating system but let me take
a shot at trying to excite you you're
why operating system may be something
you ought to pay very close attention to
there are two reasons why company goes
out of business
one they grow too slow two they grow too
fast and you know why company goes out
of business when they grow too fast
because they had a founder and a CEO
they had no desire to pay attention to
their operating system because while
they can handle 50 hundred sales a month
200 sales month all of a sudden business
takes off and the two hundred thousand
one goes to for eight hundred sixteen
hundred sales a month and the home
office can't handle it no more then
everybody's backed up then people get
complaints then no one wants to buy
again then there's rumors then you
become the next etoys where you can't
deliver on your products and deliver the
toys on time and toys that were ordered
to show up before Christmas don't show
up till January 16 then you go out of
business why because you did not pay
attention to the operating system this
you want to get a two point with your
business that eventually it's simply a
knob all it is is a knob your system is
so well defined that you just need to
control the knob boom you just need to
hire three more we can hire and afford
700 sales a month oh it's an increase we
need two are seven more it's okay we can
handle 1400 month oh it's a knob oh we
don't need to let's let go of three
people oh we don't need to let you
tiresome time oh we because it's enough
bump bump bump bump a very simple
operating system next base Devin sells
biz Devin sells us new partners how to
make your sells better how to make your
sales process better how to build some
new relationships with vendors with new
partnerships your networking annual
networking events where everybody is
there from your industry and your going
out there shaking hands with everybody
we just went to one last week which is
the annual life insurance convention you
talk to everybody meeting after meeting
after meeting after meeting hey what do
you guys got going on hey what are you
working on what's going on relationship
relationship relationship relationship
relationship that's what this is linear
exponential linear exponential if you
spend most your time in the linear part
you are not going to explode if you
spend most your time on the exponential
part you're getting ready for a major
explosion here's the problem most people
are always here this is why just because
you chose to become an entrepreneur
doesn't make you visionary just because
doesn't make you a CEO just because you
chose to become an entrepreneur doesn't
mean you're always thinking future you
could become an entrepreneur and you're
a technician like it talks about in the
book
EEMA 'the you chose to become an
entrepreneur and all you want to do is
hey we need to make the software better
I had this one guy that I work with 24/7
he spent so much time on his software
until he ran out of money and he had no
sales people in any one out of business
spent six hundred thousand dollars
complete waste the time and I said you
need sales you need to develop your
people spend time with sales people but
you don't understand if I get this
product done we're going to blow up it
has nothing to do with the product the
product is great if you don't have sales
nothing happens so you need to ask
yourself this question as you're
watching this very simple survival phase
formulation phase Expo explosion phase
plateau phase okay let's set aside
plateau phase because plateau phase is
also a whole strategy got to put
together here let's bring you back
what do you think is more important
during linear phase what's up here next
innovation can't innovative campaign
leadership development or operating
system busines themselves what do you
think's more important during survival
we're not any given it could go out of
business during survival this is decent
to focus your sales but you need to know
when to come out of it quickly and the
time you come out of it quickly as men
we need to go higher that one person
it's gonna cost us 120 per year I don't
want to do it you got to do it and you
will get judged based on that decision
you made
no one knows no one has all the info so
Samba somebody's gonna watch this video
and they're gonna say Pat should I hire
this guy's $180,000 your income at that
I don't have all the info only you do
Pat Pat this guy wants this much money
and he wants a [ __ ] I do dough should I
not do it I don't have all the info so
no matter what I say in today's video
you can figure out which of these four
you're doing well at and which of these
four you're not doing well at no matter
what I say in any one of my videos no
matter what anybody says in their books
no matter what any video you watch any
book you read any article you read
anything at the end of the day when you
become successful when you become
successful you build a very big business
that's constantly exponentially growing
you're going to get judged based on
decisions you made that nobody saw and
nobody knew while you have access to all
the information so you can send me all
the snapchats about what questions to
take and you can send me the questions
on snapchat be debate 19 is my username
but it's irrelevant because you're going
to need to make the decision yourself at
that specific moment what are you going
to do have an all access to the
information so linear here exponential
leadership development leadership
development leadership the formulation
man let's get the leadership development
leadership development leadership
development
let's get next innovative campaign next
month we're doing this next month we're
doing this next quarter will do this
next year we're doing this 2016 is a
year of this 2015 is year this 2018 is
year of this 2007 year of this next next
next next next day and then all of a
sudden boom it spikes and hopefully got
a campaign that's maybe got a three to
five year lifespan think different Apple
think different Apple and we're running
with that campaign right so
you while you're watching this some
people may say well Pat what am I going
to do with this
look there's strategy quadrant the
strategy quadrant right here you need to
your unit to yourself ask which areas
you're doing a very good job at which
areas you're not and where do you need
to pivot yourself do you need to create
an innovative campaign and what does it
look like if you actually did do it and
maybe you need to take the next 90 days
take today or whenever you watch this
video be prepared for your connects
innovative campaign for 90 days what are
we doing this month what are we doing
next month what are we doing the
following month actually ask yourself
those questions on what you're going to
do starting now the next 90 days you
would be amazed how exciting this is if
you really put a strategy together for
your business and it's definitely
exciting when a business grows and the
money starts coming because once that
starts happening let me tell you gets
very very exciting anyways with that
being said if you got any questions or
thoughts about this comment on the
bottom if you have not subscribed to
this channel yet our goal being bold
here we're going to get 2 million subs
by the end of 2017 we have some major
major plans on what we want to do with
value taming and entrepreneurs around
the world so we want to get 2 million
subs and we need your help with it if
you haven't subscribed please do so by
the way we already got people sending us
pillows because I am replacing this
pillow with anybody that wants to take
up the challenge of creating a new value
tainment custom pillow if we use it we
will recognize you and tell you that
your pillow was chosen out of all of
them for us to use at the end of every
single video in 2017 but you need to
send your pillow to 5001 Spring Valley
Road Suite number 11:55 East
that's Dallas Texas zip code
you
[Music]